bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8
week est votre émission dédiée à vos
sorties et vos loisirs au sommaire
samedi les équipes de la compagnie
déclic théâtre propose deux spectacles
d'improvisation les fonds récoltés
seront reversés à une jeune fille
atteinte d'une maladie orpheline de
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
sera ce dimanche le théâtre de deux
enquêtes policières géante
les amateurs d'investigation seront mis
à profit et jean daniel lemoine nous
présentera ses clichés il est
photographe professionnel et c'est vers
le panoramique et l'humain qu'il temps
on commence avec une première idée
sortie et c'est avec déclic théâtre la
compagnie trappistes et ses nouvelles
via kindle with il est chargé du secteur
un pro on va en parler tous les deux
jours bonjour alors la compagnie propose
deux spectacles c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure le premier il est plus à
destination des enfants
tout à fait c'est le l'impro munich
c'est un spectacle qui a presque 20 ans
aujourd'hui à déclic théâtre qui
s'appelait la gamelle est en fait c'est
un spectacle jeune public qui qui permet
en fait aux enfants de venir sur scène
et de choisir des costumes que vont
porter les comédiens et à partir des
costumes choisis en fait des personnages
vont se rencontrer et vont faire naître
une histoire et les thèmes vont être
choisis par les enfants
alors il n'y a pas de thème à proprement
dit
simplement une manière d'aborder les
histoires pour qu'elle soit un peu
burlesque ludique pour que les enfants
puissent accroché facilement mais c'est
vraiment voilà les enfants d'en choisir
trois costumes un danseur un cow-boy une
sorcière et la rencontre des trois
personnages en fait va permettre à une
histoire de niveau donc c'est un petit
peu aussi un spectacle un peu défi parce
que c'est toujours difficile d'associer
les personnages est de réussir à les
faire cohabiter dans une même un pro
mais ça ça laisse ça laisse libre cours
à des histoires un peu folle et voilà et
à notre imaginaire dans lequel les
enfants entre volontiers et la deuxième
qui est en soirée c'est plus pour les
adultes
alors tout à fait le deuxième c'est le
quintette d'improvisation qui est un
spectacle pareil qui qui inscrit depuis
20 ans à déclic théâtre le quintette
d'impro qu'on a joué déjà aux blancs
manteaux comedy club
plusieurs scènes parisiennes et de la
ferme du mousseau aussi également
pendant plusieurs années et là en fait
les impros naissent en fait du thème qui
va être proposée par le public car le
public à l'entrée de l'école de musique
va être invités à inscrire voilà son
idée de thèmes sur un petit bout de
papier qui sera tiré au sort c'est
toujours de l'impro mais ce n'est pas
des matchs alors c'est pas des matchs
n'ya pas d'arbitré il n'y a pas de ya
pas de règlement les règles sont
intégrés par les comédiens qui sont là
donc non c'est ce qui est possible de
faire ou pas faire voilà on est on est
habitué à cet exercice
et c'est pas sanctionner la seule
sanction en fait c'est c'est d'avoir
embarqué le public avec nous dans le
délire ou pas dans le délire parce que
un mot d'ordre souvent le rire ah bah se
faire plaisir ouais surtout donner du
plaisir donné à voir donne à entendre et
et oui s'amuse à créer créer quelque
chose d'assez créer de la connivence
avec le public c'est à dire réussir à
créer quelque chose de très conviviale
et de très interactif c'est le cas dans
le match d'impro le public vote
il est voilà amené à
a donné le rythme avec les musiciens sur
les applaudissements les champs tout ça
et là dans ses spectacles là le public
est forcément mis à contribution dans
les histoires parce que du coup il
choisit un petit peu aussi des
orientations dans le dense qui va être
proposé et la compagnie est prête saison
on répète beaucoup en impro alors
méfiez-vous c'est quand même une
discipline qui demande du travail s'est
pas c'est pas quelque chose
alors forcément après il ya un travail
qu'on fait + parce que parce qu'il ya
des habitudes quand on est avec des
comédiens avec lesquels on a l'habitude
improvisé maintenant sa demande de
répéter ses gammes comme un musicien il
ya beaucoup d' écoute dans l'impro il ya
comment rédiger une histoire comment
écrire une histoire en commun c'est pas
quelque chose d'aussi simple vous
réfléchissez très vite en très peu de
temps et ben en fait on justement il
faut réussir à le faire sans réfléchir
donc c'est là toute la difficulté donc
effectivement on réfléchit très vite
mais le temps qu'on met à réfléchir
souvent il est déjà trop tard donc
souvent la première idée est la bonne il
faut vite qu'elle soit acceptée par les
autres et tout ce qui est entendu et
compris par le public est forcément
intégraux histoire donc voilà c'est on a
on n'a pas le droit
il ya des erreurs qui sont forcément
fait parce que c'est de l'impro à nous
de les gommer
et allez faire oublier du public c'est
ça l'exercice emplettes et samedi
au-delà des spectacles au delà de
l'improvisation
vous avez choisi de reverser toutes vos
recettes à une jeune fille alors dire un
petit peu oui c'est une jeune trappistes
qui s'appelle marine qui
qui voilà qui est atteinte d'une maladie
orpheline et nous de toute façon le
spectacle on allait le faire s'est pas
lassé 3 euros l'entrée
c'est pas quelque chose qui allait
changer le cours de notre vie et puis
bon si ça peut en prophéties si elle
peut en profiter à sa famille en a
besoin
voilà on lui souhaite un bon
rétablissement et donc c'est pour ça que
que qu'il est important pour nous et
puis surtout voilà de mobiliser public
aussi par rapport à cette question là
parce que finalement sinon sinon les
gens sont un petit peu tout seul dès
fois dans leur coin ils savent pas trop
par quel bout le prendre c'est encore un
des moteurs de déclic aussi celle
entraide
c'est pas tant que moteur de déclic que
c'est un moteur humain de toute façon ça
je l'inscris plus dans l'humanité qui
nous engage chacun les uns les autres et
on n'est pas les seuls à trappes a
organisé ou ailleurs d'ailleurs
organiser ce genre de manifestation là
il s'avère que c'est des gens qu'on
connaît
voilà et où cet associé à ses associés
voilà c'est c'est triste ce qui leur
arrivait et on espère que ça ira bien
pour eux et que ça ira bien pour elle
surtout et voilà c'est une jeune fille
brillante qui a été récompensé plusieurs
fois en mairie pour pour ses études et
on lui souhaite justement de pouvoir
poursuivre sur cette voie là en tout cas
et donc on est plusieurs à se mobiliser
il ya des clics sur les spectacles et
aussi nos adhérents qui vont faire des
ventes de gâteaux et de boissons donc on
peut rester goûté on peut rester manger
on peut
l'occasion du maintien bien samedi tous
ensemble de faire un peu de bonnes
actions on peut dire c'est une bonne
action mais c'est surtout venez voir du
spectacle vivant et profitons-en tous
ensemble tant qu'on est là tant qu'on
est ensemble tout va bien donc voilà
percée new orleans platters donc si vous
voulez aider marine allez vous marrer un
bon coup passer une bonne journée une
bonne après-midi une bonne soirée
c'est le samedi 6 février le spectacle
famille c'est en pro mini à partir de 5
ans et à 15 heures 20h30 c'est pour le
quintette d'impro oui c'est 3 euros
l'entrée et on leur paye pas le soir si
on revient voilà une autre raison de
venir
on change de sujet on parle sur une
histoire de cinéma si vous voulez
connaître les secrets d'un tournage en
stop motion
c'est le but de l'exposition lettres de
femmes quelqu'un et la galerie de l'écu
de france à viroflay c'est le dernier
week-end pour la découvrir un sujet de
sephora namani et simon molière pendant
la première guerre mondiale simon
infirmiers soigne les soldats blessés
par les lettres d'amour envoyées par
leurs femmes lettre qui ont le pouvoir
de guérir ses seules des sans-papiers
lettres de femmes un court métrage de
dix minutes réalisé par augusto à nos
vélos en 2013 prix du public lors du
festival d'annecy la même année l'envers
du décor de ce film d'animation vous est
proposée à la galerie à l'écu de france
de viroflay à la suite du film
d'animation
j'ai pensé que ce serait
intéressant de montrer comment comment
on fait un film mais je voulais montrer
le travail dès qu'ils faut aussi qu'ils
étaient faits c'est-à-dire toute la
partie préparatoire
l'idée c'est de montrer des éléments
tous sortes d'éléments qui vont de la
conception à la réalisation c'est à dire
le film montre et de l'écriture du
scénario phase de post production en
passant par le storyboard et l'ani matic
toutes les étapes de réalisation du film
sont expliqués jusqu'au secrets du
tournage en stop motion
le ce prochain en fait c'est juste la
traduction de image par image l'image
par image c'est à dire que on a besoin
pour avoir la sensation du mouvement de
de 24 images seconde en film en image
par image
on a là on a on reconstitue
l'animation d'un personnage ou d'un
objet ce qui veut dire qu'il faut faire
24 photos pendant pourra pour obtenir
une seconde de film d'anciennes machines
ayant préfigurer le cinéma issue de la
collection d'eric l'ange sont également
présentés une exposition à découvrir
jusqu'au 7 février
ainsi qu'un ensemble de rencontres
conférences sur le même thème jusqu'au 2
avril
maxime dutil est un jeune prodige du
cyclisme français à 24 ans il est
courtisé par de nombreuses équipes et
est même invité par le sélectionneur de
l'équipe nationale du vélodrome
nationale mais la compétition ne se
déroulera pas comme prévu ça pourrait
être une histoire vraie mais c'est en
fait le pitch de la murder party que
propose ce dimanche 7 février
les associations tous qu'il y est les
compagnes la compagnie tisseur de songes
et c'est françoise de salles de l'air
mon jour vous êtes la coprésidente de la
première association tout ce qui lie
mais aussi la présidente de la compagnie
des tisseurs de songes
c'est la deuxième marqueur de repartir
wing préparé mais est-ce que déjà vous
pouvez me rappeler ce qu'est une murder
party alors une murder party c'est une
enquête policière
donc on a l'habitude de se référer un
peu au cluedo parce qu'on a tous joué le
clae d'eau enfants donc c'est une
enquête policière avec des personnages
en vrai que l'on peut interroger avec
des indices qui sont cachées un petit
peu partout certains indices étant des
preuves d'autres n'ont donc voilà c'est
une enquête policière à résoudre et vous
avez donné le pitch de l'histoire voilà
le vélodrome
pourquoi vous avez choisi ce lieu alors
le vélodrome nous a ouvert ses portes ce
qui est une excellente chose pour nous
parce que le fait que les associations
il souhaite y soit attendu accueilli
c'est vraiment très bien donc
le vélodrome c'est une coïncidence de
fait
dû à la vie inter associative qui a fait
que nous avons eu contact avec l'équipe
de l'événementiel du vélodrome qui nous
a proposé d'accueillir cette partie de
murder mais ce n'est pas seulement un
accueil n'utilisez pas le lieu comme
accueil vous avez joué l'histoire par
rapport à ça voilà alors à chaque fois
le directeur de la compagnie tisseur de
songes s'efforce d'adapter l'histoire de
créer l'histoire par rapport aux lieux
qui nous accueille la première partie
avait lieu dans le parc du château de la
couldre donc c'était une garden party
avec un lord écossais donc c'était tout
à fait adapté aux lieux et là c'est bien
sûr une histoire de cyclisme ça demande
beaucoup de temps à préparer
alors ça dure deux heures ça demande
énormément de temps de préparation
d'autant que nous sommes tous des
amateurs donc voilà donc c'est un petit
peu particulier
kenan de salles de l'air le directeur
artistique adopte une attitude très
pédagogique et nous laissent faire
évoluer nos personnages suivant les
possibilités que nous avons les uns les
autres ce qui n'est pas la même chose
dans le cadre des des moeurs d'heure
partie professionnelle puisqu'il en
organise aussi où là il fait appel à des
comédiens et où donc c'est beaucoup plus
dirigiste que ça ne l'est dans notre cas
donc là les personnages ce qui pourrait
devenir des suspects ce sont
des amateurs alors ce sont tous des
amateurs soient membres de l'association
tous qu'ils y soient membres de
l'association des tisseurs de son jeu
soit des personnes de nos réseaux en
fait amis des uns et des autres et qui
très gentiment viennent donner du temps
beaucoup d'énergie pour que ce soit
réussi
on les voit à l'image là ils répètent
ensemble comment vous faites pour
apprendre vos personnages comment ça se
passe alors c'est conçu par étape c'est
à dire que nous avons un choix de
personnages donc nous choisissons chacal
personnages qui nous correspond à peu
près ou dont on imagine qu'il va nous
corresponde et puis petit à petit
l'histoire se construit les uns par
rapport aux autres en interaction et le
toujours kenan le directeur de la
compagnie fait évoluer l'histoire
suivant ce que nous nous y sommes nous
apportons en fait il y a deux créneaux
horaires cette fois que vous avez
énormément de succès pour ceux qui
seraient tentés de divulguer et oui la
fin ils ne pourront pas ils ne pourront
pas parce que deux fins son sens
possible puisque les quatorze
personnages sont des suspects a priori
donc il y aura un véritable meurtrier
qui sera différent suivant les deux
parties est-ce qu'il ya encore de la
place pour ce il n'y a plus de place et
pourtant c'est à la suite de la première
réussite que nous avons doublé les la
possibilité puisque on a fait deux
parties il a cette fois ci et malgré le
fait qu'on accueille donc en tout 240
personnes un peu plus de 240 personnes
sur la journée de dimanche
il n'y a plus de place a été très très
vite complet alors est-ce que vous en
avez une autre dans les cartons bien sûr
bien sûr c'est un tel plaisir à
fabriquer et puis ensuite à vivre parce
qu'il ya un réel plaisir de voir toutes
ces personnes jouer autour de nous que
bien sûr on imagine en faire d'autres
on peut plus participer on peut
peut-être assister alors après les
conditions d'accueil dans le vélodrome
bon sang ça n'est pas de nous que ça
dépend il ya des règles de sécurité donc
voilà on peut assister de loin mais dans
le vélodrome lui-même le directeur le
concepteur de l'événement kenan a bien
insisté pour que toutes les activités du
vélodrome se déroule donc c'est notre
histoire qui s'intègre dans la vie
normale d'un dimanche au vélodrome donc
ceux qui font les activités pourraient
toujours être spectateur quand l'état ne
s'arrête quand même pas rien
merci françois de sales de l'air il vous
recevra un chèque pour la prochaine bird
appartiennent aussi en espérant qui est
de la place pourrait peut-être trois
créneaux dans la journée dans un canon
scié en tout cas c'est une affaire à
suivre
on change complètement de sujets ont pas
en littérature puisque vous en avez
l'habitude maintenant chaque semaine on
vous propose de découvrir une idée
lecture avec l'équipe de la librairie du
pavé du canal
cette semaine c'est envoyé spécial de
jean echenoz et c'est stéphanie férial
qui vous le fait découvrir
donc je vous présente le nouveau roman
de jean echenoz envoyé spécial aux
éditions de minuit qui est un vrai joyau
est une vraie pépite à lire c'est une
opération en fait un peu abracadabrante
d'une un pastiche en fait de film
d'espionnage
un peu à la ss 117 où il essaye de
monter une opération de mission il leur
faut un pigeon si je puis dire ça va
tomber sur constance constance qui
s'ennuie un peu dans sa vie et qui va
prendre parce qu'avec qu'ils m'appellent
va être voilà on va essayer de la forme
et pour une mission et qui va prendre ça
un peu comme des voix des vacances
inattendu et qui va partir yeux fermés
voilà c'est assez burlesque complètement
abracadabrant drôle mais vraiment drôle
avec surtout un
rythmes endiablés avec des
rebondissements totalement inattendu
s'est intelligemment fait c'est pas
loufoque
c'est abracadabrant et rocambolesque
surtout intelligemment fait et surtout
avec une style absolument géniale qui
fait justement inscrits et d'autre le
fait qu'on soit vraiment mais en extase
devant ce bouquin moi j'ai eu un vrai
vrai coup de coeur c'est un vrai bonheur
à lire escales surtout c'est qu'il nous
met vraiment dans un régal total de
lecture voilà jean echenoz envoyé
spécial aux éditions de minuit elle
termine sa 7,8 week-end le magazine
sorties et loisirs avec la découverte du
trail de jean daniel lemoine il est
photographe professionnel et nous a
rejoint en plateau bonjour et vous êtes
accompagné comme chaque fois par claude
chose le président de l'union régionale
photographique bonjour bonjour mélanie
je me tourne vers vous claude cette
semaine on s'intéresse au tribe jean
daniel lemoine pourquoi écouter jean
daniel et un photographe de très longue
date
je vous parle pas depuis quand il fait
de la photo parce que c'est ça remonte à
très loin mais on peut dire qu'il a été
un pionnier dans la photo de
photographie numérique
si vous êtes telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui et jean-daniel s'occupe est
passionné par le panoramique
donc je pense que le mieux c'est de lui
laisser la parole pour qu'il nous
explique le pourquoi donc moi je vais te
poser tout de suite une première
question pourquoi le panoramic son
haleine
peut-être qu'après de longues pratique
dans le viseur dans le petit viseur de
l'appareil photo j'avais envie de voir
plus large et c'est vrai que le
panoramique avec toute l'histoire de
cette technique
ça m'a incité à les explorer plus avant
j'ai donc commencé à faire des petits
panoramique et puis après je me suis re
déployés sur des des techniques beaucoup
plus sophistiqué qui ont permis de faire
dépannera des dons aujourd'hui j'espère
pouvoir faire des tirages de plusieurs
mètres de long et plusieurs mètres de
haut rentrer tout de suite dans la
technique vous parlez de petits
panoramique il ya des panneaux khalid
différents dépendant de des
caractéristiques de l'appareil oui très
certainement il faut avoir plus
l'appareil est performant plus il
permettra de faire des panoramiques cran
mais c'est vrai que savaient les
panoramiques historiquement sans
remonter à très loin au début du xviii
19e siècle il y avait sont appelés les
panoramas c'était des peintures qui
faisait 110 mètres de long sur 14 mètres
de haut et qui étaient dans des rotondes
dont il reste d'ailleurs quelques
vestiges à paris puisque le
le théâtre de marigny et une de ces
rotonde de même que le théâtre des
champs elysées donc vous voyez déjà à
cette époque les gens avaient soif de
voir des paysages et découvrir des
panoramas et aujourd'hui la technique du
panoramique c'est reprendre un petit peu
cet esprit d'élargir sa vue vers
d'autres horizons
ça c'est ouvrir son regard on serait que
le 16/9 exactement sortir du cadre de
l'appareil photographique
on avait passé plusieurs de vos photos à
l'écran et on en a ressorti une on va la
voir à l'écran elle et elle est prise
dans une galerie mais ce que je trouve
très étonnant sur cette photo le jeune
vous n'expliquez c'est cet effet bombé
cet effet bombé trois fois quand vous
l'avez fait
alors c'est tout simplement un endroit
qui est presque fermé c'est à dire un
endroit où il ya un panneau de fonds et
deux panneaux latéraux et les
déformations vous voyez son dû bien sûr
aux déformations de l'optique mais pas
tout à fait en fait c'est la réalité qui
est comme ça nous on voit de cette façon
là mais là il rétabli grâce à notre
notre cerveau l'oeil et le cerveau vont
rétablir la réalité de l'objet
photographié donc ne pensez pas que
c'est une déformation de l'optique
mais c'est une vue très large qui
entraîne forcément des altérations de la
façon dont des perçu la naturelle
sénatus est naturelle et léonard de
vinci avait déjà dans en son temps
découvert qu' il y avait des des vues
panoramiques qui ce qui faisait que on
pouvait trouver ses courbes un petit peu
partout même dans la peinture
dans la peinture de cette époque je me
tourne vers vous maintenant parce qu'on
on parlait de son goût pour le
panoramique mais le travail de jean
daniel lemoine c'est aussi les gens et
leur métier et c'est ça qui vous aussi
vous tenez à coeur voilà je sais aussi
ce qui nous tenait à coeur parce que
depuis que je connais jean daniel cible
et il est toujours incité de dire que
nous sommes sur une planète qui compte
quand même 6 milliards d'individus et
bons souvent les photographes s'ingénie
à faire des photos avec personne dessus
donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons le droit à l'image mais je
voudrais que jean-daniel nous explique
un petit peu ciblées pourquoi lui à
chaque fois il photographie les gens et
dans les pattes dans les photos que vous
avez que vous avez vu certainement vous
avez je connais son travail il a fait
des séries complètes avec un prenant des
gens dans leur milieu de travail
peut-être qu'il va nous expliquer le
pourquoi témoigner de son environnement
c'est peut-être faire du paysage mais le
paysage et il a quelque chose de pérenne
quelquefois et dans 25 50 ans il sera
toujours le même
alors que les gens échangent tous les
jours et apporter ce témoignage sur la
société qui nous entoure vraiment en
grande largeur
c'est vraiment une passion pour moi j'ai
j'ai presque l'impression que j'étais un
devoir de rendre compte de toutes ces
personnes de tous ces groupes de deux
commerçants de l'association
c'est ça qui est passionnant c'est de
figer un instant donné une vue sur la
société actuelle est posée par contre
alors oui et non en fait j'ai je leur
demande de ne pas trop bouger sans
semble qu'ils posent leur demande de ne
pas se déplacer car effectivement le
panoramic ils ont fait de la de
plusieurs vues placés côte à côte et ce
sera catastrophique si le bouger entre
de vue ont parlé des gens notamment il
ya aussi une photo si je me trompe pas
elle a été présent au marché de
versailles on va la voir à l'écran gmail
vous m'en parler un petit peu de cette
photo alors vous marchez dire ça il y a
ces commerçants qui sont formidables ils
sont là ils sont accueillants et g j'ai
fait le tour du marché de versailles
pour aller à leur rencontre et leur
proposer de faire une photo de leur de
leur boutique
c'est vrai que c'est pas très large
alors avec un appareil traditionnel
c'est pratiquement impossible de rendre
compte de la totalité de ses boutiques
mais avec l'appareil panoramique le
miracle fait que sans avoir beaucoup de
recul
on est capable de rendre compte de façon
modérée de faire un inventaire il s'agit
pas de rendre compte de la réalité des
des lignes mais de faire un inventaire
donnez la réalité du mieux même si
l'image paraît déformés voilà exactement
chaque objet chaque objet est là et le
panoramique à quelque chose d'un discret
quelque part parce que quand on regarde
les photos et qu'on les a grandi et on
les a grandi on arrive à trouver des
détails qui reflète vraiment la
condition sociale dans lequel on se
trouve de l'environnement dans lequel on
se trouve
et c'est très très indiscret comme
appareil parce que les gens tireront
battante qu'il se montre au fond alors
on a beaucoup parlé du résultat on a
regardé les photos moi j'aimerais qu'on
parle un peu de technique aussi parce
que le panoramique on connaît tous avec
nos téléphones on l'a tous fait c'est
pas toujours très propres comment vous
travaillez vous je je je suis pas très
loin de la technique du téléphone je
prends mon appareil et je vais le faire
tourner sur lui-même de façon à ce que
le plan focal des vues successives se
retrouve sur un cylindre est en fait
c'est le développer de ce cylindre qui
va constituer l'image finale le
smartphone ou les appareils numériques
aujourd'hui en les ans les en effet en
tournée on obtient exactement ce
résultat-là alors dans la technique
j'utilise je prends plusieurs vues des
jeunes à côté des autres en faisant
tourner mon appareil sur lui-même et
ensuite je les assemble avec un logiciel
qui qu'ils ont un produit à part du de
l'appareil photo dans les panoramiques
qui sont faits avec les smartphones ou
d'autres avec les appareils des
appareils numériques
ce logiciel est inclus dans le dans
l'appareil lui-même mais ne peut pas
donner des résultats en termes de
précision des résultats analogues à ceux
d'un appareil qui va décrire petit à
petit et l'espace environnant peut-être
s'entraîner soi même chez soi oui avec
un appareil normal il suffit de dison de
poser l'appareil verticalement sur un
index que vous allez tenir devant vous
poser l'appareil
et vous le fessier de le faire tourner
en c'est une petite gymnastique qui
demande un peu de souplesse mais on
arrive à d'excellents résultats
et ben pourquoi pas vous laisser tenter
merci à tous les deux d'être venu en
plateau pour nous parler de ce sujet de
photographique l'autre chose on vous
retrouve bientôt pour nous donner les
résultats du concours que nous
organisons tous les mois vous pouvez me
faire un petit rappel le thème du
prochain concours c'est le lot
l'autoportrait on précise bien ce ne
sont pas des selphy c'est l'autoportrait
nous avons d'ailleurs reçu déjà quelques
photos qui sont qui sont très
intéressants on peut envoyer jusqu'au 6
mars puisque nous avons les vacances
scolaires donc nous avons et la
présentation des photos sera le onze
pour envoyer les photos bc très simple
rédaction
et puis je voudrais vous parler aussi de
d'exposition en quelques mots votre
exposition exposition donc à voisins le
bretonneux donc au centre alfred de
vigny sur la manière de visiter déjà les
jardins de versailles un écrit de louis
xiv qu'il est il a écrit six guides et
je vous guiderai à travers mon propos ce
sera le moyen de découvrir ce que vous
venez souvent nous parler de
photographier le 7-8 week-end c'est
terminé je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivi la semaine prochaine c'est mikel
et demi d'euros qui vous présentera à
son tour des idées sorties et loisirs
d'ici là je vous souhaite un excellent
week-end